hello everyone and welcome back to the
finals of the Grantchester we are in the
tiebreaks so the to classical games
ended in a draw then the two rapid games
ended in a draw and after four blades
games
the result was equal one game was won by
Magnus won by Maxime holographing
rapid tiebreaks two games will be played
and if these two games are drawn of or
if the score is equal then they go into
the Armageddon so this is a this is an
insane game you know if it was up to us
the people who enjoy the show every game
would be like this they should they
should really make a movie about this
game it has everything and I don't know
I would probably ask you to pause the
video like five times during this video
because the positions that arise during
the game are just beautiful so that
being said let's let's check it out
Magnus with the white pieces and this is
a game one of the rapid tiebreaks opens
with E 4 we have C 5 the Sicilian
defense is on the board they will be
repeating the game they already played
in the classical time format up to a
certain move so Knight to f3 d6 we have
d4 C CAP first Knight characters we have
a Knight to f6 Knight to c3 and a6 we go
for the knight or variation Bishop to g5
Magnus again goes for his Bishop to g5
nf3
idea we have E 6 and now F 3 so the same
idea as in game 1 of the classical time
format with h6 pushing the bishop back
Russia P 3 and B 5 maxime also doesn't
change anything since he was very happy
with that game with a3 preventing B 4
and now Knight B to d7 this was a new
move when we were showing the classical
game but it's not a new move now since
the two of them already played it in the
classical time section so Queen d2
Magnus prepares the Castle queenside
Bishop to b7 and now a queenside castle
we have h5 so everything the same as in
the classical game King b1 a nice
prophylactic move and now Bishop to e7
and here in the class 4 game between the
two of them Magnus went Queen to a 1 but
here he goes rook to G 1 this supposed
to be an improvement on on game 1 so
we'll see how
we have rook to c8 Maxime continues in
the same fashion as he did he doesn't
seem this changes things all that much
for Bishop to e2 and now still waiting
with the development of the Queen first
it goes in Knight b6 now the idea is you
want to get the knight to see for the
same way you did in in the classical
game but also you can get this Knight to
d7 t e5 and also this knight can come to
c4 so we'll see we'll see what happens
now that the knight can come to see for
now Magnus goes Quinte one freeing the
this diagonal so the bishop can retreat
the c1 if needed
Knight F to be seven and the now g4 okay
we have h captures rook captures now the
g7 point is under attack so you do have
to defend it Bishop goes back and now
you could choose between Bishop g5 just
attacking the Queen but Magnus goes back
with roof to G - just guards D H to pawn
we have Knights the e5 now both Knights
are now ready to jump in on the c-4
square and then now F for Magnus even
forces it with Knight e to c4 Bishop the
c1 and only now Queen to c7
the the general idea when you when you
play such positions you you will want to
capture on a3 if possible remove the
defender of the c3 Knight so then the
Queen can just capture it and here you
could go rogue d3 rook g3 just add a
defender to the c3 Knight but Magnus
before going rogue d3 he doesn't want to
block his own lights for the first two
trades once Bishop captures Knight
captures and only now rook to d3 we have
g6 now so now the dark square bishop can
move you want to put it to g7 to control
this diagonal b3 Magnus pushes the
knight back but here MVL doesn't doesn't
react in a way that Magnus wanted him to
react he just goes Bishop to g7 and here
it's a it's a really crazy line for
example if you accept the knight beat
captures you cannot move the rook if you
move the rook just Bishop captures here
and now you cannot recapture because of
Queen b6 check picks up the rook so what
you would have to do after B captures on
c4 you're gonna just have to do
something else
the rook is off-limits but what to do
you could go rook to g3 or even better
you could go Knight captures on e6 this
is kind of the point of the line where
now you can either just accept the
knight right away or deliver one check
let's say Bishop to b2 and only now
except tonight and then now rogue dg3
and now white will continue the attack
and the King side whereas black of
course will continue on the Queen side
really insane stuff but calculating this
in a rapid game it is simply too much so
first Magnus goes Queen to d1 so what do
you do here adds another defender to the
to the night here and now comes Queen to
a5
mvl just continues the attack now he's
ready to capture on a3 so here again
really a lot of things can happen here
for example you can still go Knight
captures on e6 Bishop captures on c3 and
then now B captures on c4 this is really
just insane stuff as it's almost
incredible to believe that white can
survive this now route capture some d6
and now blacks attack is stopped because
the rook captures on e6 will will finish
in mate if black allows this so black
has the block and then you get rook
captors and g6 adding another attacker
here so just rook captures and on these
six you will have to pick it up Queen
captures and now we bring a defender to
the to the e6 pawn and well the game
continues but it's really just a
complete mess
so after this Quint a5 move Magnus still
doesn't capture on e6 he first goes f5
and this is now again really really
exciting stuff just to show what happens
for example if you continue with Knight
captures on a3 Bishop captures and Queen
captures now you get F captures on e6
Bishop captures on d4 now Queen f3
threatening capture some f7 followed by
Queen d7 mate
so rook the f8 you will now recapture
the bishop and now if captures on e6
opening up an attack against the Queen
Queen h3 now going after at this point
here also the knight on c3 is defended
so it's not a problem
rook f6 defending and the game continues
so but white should be
what should be able to defend this and
even put pressure on black so this is
what happens if MDL continues with night
captures on a three here mvl just goes
back with the night he goes Knight to e5
idea being that okay if you capture on
g6 I can recapture with the night but
here Magnus plays an even better idea he
pushes b4 pushes the Queen back Queen to
b6 now captures on g6 we have Knight
captures on g6 and now Bishop to e3 and
all of a sudden you can see that
Maxine's attack is is just gone and it's
basically Magnus who's in the driver's
seat now threatening all sorts of nasty
discoveries with the night it's just a
hard position to play with black and
here there are there are no good options
for black but it's it's a rapid game and
MBL is an extremely creative player and
MVL found a Bishop to h6 and this is
just crazy stuff so feel free to pause
the video here for you know as long as
you want and try to find the best idea
for white in this position while I give
you a couple of seconds you know for you
to decide for those of you who are able
to do it congratulations on finding such
a brilliant idea
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show it's Knight captures on
e6 this is the move that that wins for
white but it's extremely extremely
complicated point is you have to give up
the bishop here and now you play rook
captures on d6
you attack the Queen Bishop to c6 blocks
and now Knight to d5 is just winning
since if you capture well you lose the
Queen and if you move the Queen then you
get Knight d2 c7 with check and now you
cannot capture if you capture then you
get a rogue d8
check which you can give up the Queen
but if you don't if you go King g7 then
it's just Queen d6 check King goes to f6
Knight the f8 a discovery
you're gonna go to g7 just rook captures
ng 6f captures and g6 and now Queen
captures and g6 will be made so this is
one way to do about it if after this
Knight d2 c7 check you pick up a with
the row but if you go King to e7 it's a
bit different but still you just capture
the bishop so it's not a problem
a black doesn't really have a
would move you're not about to allow
Quinta d6o you can bring a rook into the
game rook cd8 now you will capture it
once captures captures and here you will
just go back Knight to d5 check King f8
and now rook G captures ng 6f captures
and now Queen to f3 check is enough
because whatever you do
the queen is is infiltrating and that's
that's pretty much it King g7 you're
gonna get the Queen f6 charity engage 7
Queen captures on g6 check and you are
getting made it very soon so after
Bishop to h6 Knight captures and e6 is
the way to go Magnus goes with a
different idea he goes Knight captures
on b5 it's still playable but it
requires a lot of precision well that
the previous line requires a lot of
precision as well it's just that this
one who really requires it here of
course the Queen is under attack so
Bishop captures on e3 the best move now
comes Knight captures and d6 with Czech
King the e7 and now again I will ask you
to pause the video and try to find a way
out of this madness while I give you a
couple of seconds for those of you who
were able to do that congratulations on
finding Knight captures on f7 it's
really not an easy move to choose since
you can grab a lot of material here on
on this side but Knight captures on f7
is just deadly because after King
captures you again have this Queen f3
infiltrating move and then well now
there's a double attack on the bishop
the king is in check if you move the
King you lose the night if you play
something like Bishop to f4 just rook
captures and g6 is enough for the King
capture screen captures on f4 and now
once the rook comes to g3 which cannot
be prevented it's a game over even if
you give some chip here King B - you're
gonna capture here room g3 check just
wins the game because you either have to
give up the Queen or you go back and
then it's just Queen check here and the
Queen g6 again is mate however Carlson
went for Knight captures on b7 which
still is a great move we have Knight to
e5 now now not interested in capturing
then you can just capture the bishop so
first Knight to e5 adding another
attacker to the rook but now rook
captures an ether
basically offering a rook although it's
not so it's not all it's not possible to
capture the rook if you captures rook
then again you allow Queen to d6
infiltrating and after the King moves
you're not just nice to d5 is is deadly
he captures or you're getting made it so
he captures Queen captures with check
and now whenever you do it's just over
the rook is under attack this will fall
with to check if King d7 then you just
continue grabbing material Queen d5
check King g7 have you repeat Queen e5
check and now you've freed a lot of
files for the attack King here Knight
the c5 check comes and well you will
simply not be able to wiggle out King d8
Queen to f6 with check King c7 Queen if
you try to run away Queen to e7 were to
check King to c6 and now you can even
start bringing other pieces into the
attack oh it's a Queen d7 check kink the
b6 and now this will be made you didn't
even have to use your rook however
whatever you do you cannot capture the
rook on e3 so night the c4 now attacking
the rook from from c4 but now comes Luke
to d3 again threatening to just
infiltrate would rook to d7 check with
Queen captures on b7 and now Knight to
a4 here Magnus is preparing Knight to
the c5 he wants to bring this night to
c5 it will be an excellent piece
defending b4 pawn then you can start
moving the rook and the Queen
so rook H to d8 offering some traits
here and here Magnus have to just
capture captures captures go Queen e1
defend the e4 pawn next you're gonna go
Knight the c5 add another defender to
the pawn here you're gonna go Queen to
c3 rook to d2 and it's going to be just
a well a winning game for white but
Magnus won tonight the c5 here and this
now just doesn't work so once again feel
free to pause the video and try to find
why it doesn't work while I give you a
couple of seconds for those of you who
were able to find it congratulations but
it's not real captures on c5 if you find
if you found that rook after sandy eight
still wins for white even though you
cannot capture the rook here because
after Knight captures on a3 and king c1
you don't really have a good move
it's even white
for tricks for example if Queen captures
on e4 you even have some tricky mates
with rook e8 check King captures and now
check King g7 and now Queen to d8 will
be made as the two points completely
block the King from escaping
so after 95 if you found rocky a person
d3 then congratulations now it's here
Magnus just started you know nodding his
head in in disgust since it's a well he
missed it
obviously you cannot capture with d3
because now recaptures and c5 just wins
you cannot recapture the rook and the
knight is protected so here n VL would
just be up up a whole night
so after look D 3 we have Knight
captures on d3 and now Knight captures
on a3 with check King c1 and now Queen
captures on e4 really from from that
position to this position that's the
beauty of chairs here Magnus goes rook
to f2 gets his rook out of harm's way
and now again pause the video and try to
find a winning move for Maxine well I'll
give you a couple of seconds for those
of you who were able to do it
congratulations it's not an easy move to
find a nice centralizing Queen d4 well
the Queen was centralized on e4 but d4
just has more threats so now the point
is Quinta a1 check is unstoppable
quint a 1 check followed by rook
captures and c2 will finish the game and
if you block it with nice to be - just a
queen captures rook so you cannot defend
against both Quinta a1 check and Queen
captures rook that would be the game but
and we'll missed it MV L played Quinta
III check which only helps Magnus
Magnusson L goes King to be 2 we have
Knights the c4 check King to a2 and now
tonight back to d6 now giving Magnus a
moment to catch his breath we have Queen
to h5 immediately the the most active
square for the Queen Queen g4 also was
possible
we have Knights to f5 now you are you
are you do have a lot of pressure on the
f7 pawn so Knights the f5 just blocking
it and now look to eat you getting the
Queen out the way Queen to g1
now asking are you perhaps interested in
maybe grabbing the knight on f5 however
if you do play Knight captures
five it doesn't work because of rook
captures on C - that's the that MVL
nasty plan so now if you capture then
the Queen can easily be captured and if
you don't capture it then just rook
captures rook so you don't really do
gain anything by it
so Queen f3 now allowing rook captures
and c2 but also natural captures and c2
but first Queen to b6 now again
preparing a five black wants to open up
lines in front of the White King we have
Knight the e5 now really hoping to get
this knife to c6 at some point for
example if you capture here the knight
c6 just Forks the king and the Queen so
you will have to give up give up the
exchange here we have Queen tab e5 by
maksim and here again
Magnus just has to play Queen to e4 a
nice centralizing move with the Queen at
another defender alright so this guy
here and the game continues
however Magnus after queen bee five
plates e4 he really wants to get this
captures and the knight to c6 check but
this now again doesn't work for the
final time pause the video and try to
find the winning move for Maxime while I
give you a couple of seconds for those
of you who were able to do it
congratulations and finding a move you
should well most often not play and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show its Queen to a4 check why is it
Queen to f4 check well you kinda have to
now block with la queenie if you remove
the king then b4 pawn falls with two
checks so Queen to a3 captures captures
and now the move you had to find f6
pushes the knight back and the wins the
c4 pawn yes this rollercoaster of a game
you know is is decided by the by the
winning of the c4 pawn so nice to d3 and
now rook captures and c4 we have nice
the c5 going after the two pawns here
but now Knight to d5 attacking the rook
and the defending the e6 pawn we looked
for and now the move that really finds
you know solves everything
a5 now this is protected
and there's no e6 target anymore you
cannot capture because you lose the
night so here Magnus just went back in
gate two now comes rook captures and now
Knight to d3 attacking the rook Knight
back to b5 now finding a nice nice
little maneuver now if you captured the
rook and Knight to c3 check picks up the
rook on e4
so here Magnus just traded a capture
snipe captures and now we have this
endgame where it's two against one with
two with Knights on the board Maxime
starts pushing f5 with King to be two
King to f6 we've came to see two King to
was sorry Knight the d4 check King to d3
and now tonight's the f3 check going
after the pawn here H 3 and E 5 so this
is of course winning for black but you
know when the time is low anything can
happen and if you manage to grab at
least one of those points sacrifice
tonight and then get a maybe a stalemate
position or a drawing position would be
excellent for Magnus King III that night
back to h4 and now Knight to d5 with
check King g5 we have Knight to e7
and now Knight back to g6 of course
Magnus cannot afford a night trade we
have Knight back to c8 and now Knight to
f4 and now this wins the pawn there's no
way around it we have h4 captures now
Magnus goes back but just King to g5 now
it's 2 points against zero points of
course completely winning king of three
we have Knight to g6 again offering a
trade Knight to d5 and now efore with
Czech king to e3 and now Knight to e5 so
here if Maxim wants to continue pushing
his pawns he needs this night to be
undies sixth to defend both of the
points so this can be pushed with the D
would be for pawn being defended so came
to d4 now comes Knight to g4 he's gonna
have to wiggle around with the night a
bit to achieve this setup nights to c7
we have Knight to H 2 now King III
Knights the f1 with check King F 2 we
have Knights to d2 King III Knights the
c4 with check King before and not nice
to d6 finally the night is here and the
points are protected problem is if you
go if you go for the night then black
just starts pushing the pawns
and gives up the night so that that's a
problem for white knight ESX check we
have King g4 and now King to e3 but now
you can start slowly but surely pushing
your pawns we have King the g3 first
forcing the Knights to move away we have
night to d4 end of course only now f4
check with King e2 now comes King to g2
Knight the e6 attacking the f4 pawn but
now if the Richard King - III and now
King the g3 check
we have Knight to f4 now you cannot go
tonight here because Knight checks just
picks up the night on f4 so Knight to f4
check nice the c4 check still we have
King capped for Sonny for not going for
the knight of course and then now f2 the
point is now being promoted nights the e
to check in here we have King to g4 and
it was in this position of 82 that
Magnus Carlsen resigned the game and
what a victory for maxim for sure
holograph here is nice because next move
f1 Queen comes and there's nothing you
can do about it of course that's
completely a winning for black so really
an insane game it took us a while to go
through the game like I said you could
really make a movie about this game yeah
this is a game one from the rapid
tiebreaks
I don't know if I will be making game 2
so for those of you who maybe don't know
maybe you know stop watching the video
as I will now announce it but Maxie
marshal de Graaff won this match as the
next game ended in a draw it was a
really crazy game as well but it ended
in a draw so it's
mvl who proceeds to the finals so Magnus
will face 11 for fourth who will be
third in the Grantchester and of course
maxime beaugeois will face dinkler and
for the finals of the of the
Grantchester so really really insane
stuff III do hope you enjoyed it I would
like to thank Chris Picard for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot - really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos
serum think all for watching and I will
see you soon
continuing the coverage of the
Grantchester continue to check up on
your wonderful suggestions as I've
received a few of them since we've been
covering the Grantchester and of course
when we finish with everything that's
currently going on in
just world we are continuing with our
next big saga so thank you all I will
see you soon and have an excellent race
- really